just this in my opinion I'm not speaking
for the administration so I will preface
that with very clear caveat the rich are
not paying their fair share in any
nation that Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton not speaking for the Obama
administration for which she is well
Secretary of State fairness like beauty
and pornography is in the eye of the
beholder
but Madam Secretary seems to have a very
squirrelly understanding of just how
much the rich are paying as a percentage
of federal tax liabilities using 2006
data for instance the New York Times
estimated that the average household
paid about 21 percent of their income in
income payroll corporate and excise
taxes households in the top income
quintile paid about 26% of their income
in those same taxes and get this the top
one percent of households are 19 percent
of all income but paid over twenty eight
percent of all federal taxes paying in a
lot more than you get out that doesn't
strike me as fair the rich are different
than you and me they've got more money
and politicians are different too they
rarely say what they really mean perhaps
what Secretary Clinton and the
administration for which she does not
speak means is that the rich can always
pay more than they're already paying
that would explain why she and the
president are lobbying to let the bush
tax cuts expire at the end of the year a
policy that would raise all sorts of
taxes on all sorts of people which
doesn't sound all that fair either for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie